you ever wonder why we hate setbacks why
you and I why we as human beings cannot
stand being publicly humiliated or
losing in front of our peers family
members and even worse than that worse
than it you ever noticed what it does to
us right afterwards we kind of go back
and we kind of settle down and we kind
of don't want to try it again because
we're not good at it and in reality
anything we do for the first time we're
not good at so we don't want to do it a
second or third or a fourth or fifth or
hundredth time look what happened to
sleek end what's the lesson that
happened to me years ago with my dad but
I want to share with you what happened
this weekend my son so we're up there we
check him to ski lessons my seventy or
my six year old and my six year olds
going up he's taking ski lessons he does
a great job the next day we take him on
the mountains and they're going down and
at this crazy place they're going down
the sled and they're jumping and there's
these jumps and all this other stuff so
what are the ones he says push me so my
brother-in-law
pushes my son and he's just flying so
fast off the hits to jump and then it
flips and he can't control it BAM hits
his head on the ground okay and my son
when he has a painful experience he
jumped up and down and he's just
screaming he's not the one that wants
you to hug him he jumps up and down
because he's so angry with the pain
right so we look up there's blood on the
ground he's bleeding his lip is swollen
his bleeding hardcore so I take him to
the car I said come on man let's go to
the car we go to the car my
brother-in-law's goes and grabs paper
towel he comes I take my B me out and
I'm putting it on his lip and he's in
tears and I say hey by the way with my
daughter right there daddy come on Sena
come out here come out here turn this
story that's close the door while I'm
telling this story but come out and join
me can you say hello to everybody say
hello okay so his bleeding come here
baby
he's bleeding and we're sitting in the
car and then all of a sudden it's done
but he's still like not happy about it
and he's shaking a little bit I said
okay let's go back on the mountain he
says no I said we're going back on the
mountain he says no I'm not going back
on the mountain
Dylan we're going back on the mountain
daddy I'm not going back on the mountain
so finally I said Dylan you got to get
back on the mountain and I reminded him
of a story of what happened one time
when his sister fell in the pool right
in front of them and we were all there
but he panicked and then she panicked
himself and he didn't want to get in the
pool and I had to keep him in the pool
one time for an hour and half from the
moment it happens for his fears to go
away so I reminded him of that I said
you remembered I says I do I said how
good of a slow Marek today is I'm a very
good swimmer so in this moment you and I
have to go face this publicly
humiliating loss that we just had a
setback of painful experience and you're
not hurt to the point where you can't do
it and you trust your daddy because I
would never put you in a situation
that's gonna be bad for you so as I do
daddy I said let's get back up there
take him up there he's nervous he's not
happy about it we put him up again we
push him down he goes through it goes
through jump and then all of a sudden
forgets about it next thing you know
he's out there doing it again for the
entire time and he's okay how did I
start this video so do you ever wonder
how we don't like setback some public
humiliating loss in front of our peers
and family members and we don't like to
do things for the first time you know
sometimes when we are raised in overly
protective families typically a mother
that's overprotective sometimes a father
that's overprotective that habit of what
happens in that moment while our parents
think they're doing the noble thing
because they're loving us and they're
protecting us and immediately they're
taking us away from that setback or the
experience that we had that was
humiliating they're actually teaching a
long term habit of throwing in the towel
and giving up our warm paint they're not
doing it intentionally like parenting
doesn't come with a manual the only
reason I did this with my kids is
because I remember one time with my dad
the while I'm in Iran my dad wouldn't
let my mom come to the park with us
because every time she would come to the
park with us if I fell down or something
happened to me she would panic and we
would panic because she's a mother she
wants to protect her kids so one day
we're at a park and I'm going around the
track all these kids are on bicycles and
I'm going around the track and I'm going
around the track and I told my dad I
want to go the opposite way he says no
you can't go too I said dad I'm gonna go
the opposite way because it seems faster
when people pass you by
he says you're gonna get hit I said that
I'm not gonna get hit I'm like 78 years
old
he says if you get hit I'm not gonna do
nothing for you because I told you don't
do this this is don't worry about that
I'm okay so I'm going I'm going I'm
going I'm going I'm going
this one kid is coming to run he's
waving at his dad he doesn't see me so
he's coming straight at me
Wham I hit the kid I fly off the bike I
hit the ground and the cement is the
rough cement in Iran and I'm bleeding
all over the place I mean just blood all
over the place and I kid his crime his
mommy and daddy come up to me and what's
wrong with you kid why would you go this
way where are your parents
where is your mom and dad and I'm
looking around and I'm not crying here's
why I'm not crying I'm looking around
and I look at my dad and I point on my
dadís and my dad's right over there
and my dad's pointing at the water
faucet let the pretty colored the hose
he says go wash up and I'm looking down
to see what his reaction is he has zero
reaction so I'm like okay then it must
not be that big of a deal this is like
normal this kind of stuff happens I went
up I wash my face wash my hands wash my
elbows came back he says so which way
you want to go now I said I think I'm
gonna go told me to go then I wonder why
I went and I enjoy the rest of my time
but the moral this story is look the
next time you're doing a sales call or
an appointment or you're doing something
for the first time in the world of
business and it's scary and you did a
best-of mistake and it's your first
mistake and it's humiliating it's
embarrassing get back on the mountain
again get back on the mountain again you
have to get back on the mountain again
in that moment don't even let a day go
by without you getting back on the
mountain again if you have a bad call
make 50 more calls if you have a bad
appointment go do three more
appointments if you have a bad
presentation go do three more
immediately right afterwards to make
sure that doesn't stay with you we're 5
10 15 20 years down the line you're
gonna look back and say the only reason
I didn't make it to where I'm at right
now is because I'm afraid of losing and
I'm afraid of the first publicly
humiliating experience I have any time I
do something for the first time so
before you become great you must be good
before you become good you're bad and
before you're bad you're
so it's okay just gotta go to do the
faces and be patient with yourself but
face the loss it's normal we all go
through it and eventually become very
good at it but
Merry Christmas from ours - yours hope
you had a great Christmas I remember all
four when the first time I came here to
Lake Tahoe I was broke nothing to my
name and but I had a dream and I sat in
a cabin with a few few of our friends
and we went up the mountain and all I
thought about to myself is let me take
over the world one day you know people
have no idea how much fire is in my
belly at the time I'm thinking oh my
gosh I can't wait for all this stuff
that I want to become a reality
all four is what 15 16 years ago I was a
25 year old 24 year old kid with a dream
and didn't know if it was gonna happen
or not but I wanted to become a reality
and eventually it did so merry Christmas
to you hope you had a good one looking
forward to having the killer 2020 and if
you haven't yet subscribed to the
channel please do so as well take you
everybody love you Oh bye
you
[Music]